[Music]
i recently bought a new car but since i
mostly travel in town i soon realized
that 700 car payments plus insurance was
just ridiculous and it cost more than my
mortgage i sold it and got a used
vehicle that's fully paid for with gas
prices rising i'm relieved to no longer
have that monthly payment yeah
that's the way to do it
yeah the car payments can get out of
control real quick
and like we were talking about earlier
you can justify yourself
into purchasing anything oh well i'm
this is the car that i use to go to work
it has to be i got to be comfortable i
mean you know i spend more time on my
car than i do uh at my house or whatever
it is
what makes that 700 a month car better
than the paid off car for you
let's name the okay it has bluetooth
it has heated seats heated seats and it
has a really sick spoiler
and so i'm willing to pay 700 a month by
the way the average car payment now is
83 months
so i'm willing to spend 700 a month
for heated seats bluetooth and a spoiler
really
that's really what you want to pay 700 a
month for of course not yeah and so this
isn't a judgment of anyone who has a car
payment it's an understanding that quite
often we are tricked by car dealerships
by corporations by financing
into buying something we can't afford
we're paying a bunch of money
for something that isn't adding the
commiserate value to our lives in fact
it's extracting the value because now i
have to pay 700 a month
to pay for the car that takes me to work
so i can earn the 700 a month to pay for
the car that takes me to work it's like
well wait a minute if i didn't have this
car payment maybe i wouldn't be tethered
to
the income the same way i am now and
what are the other things that if i
untethered from the credit card debt
from the student loan debt from the
oversized house or oversized apartment
if i untethered from these debts from
these monthly payments would i get back
a piece of my freedom because then i
could still go to the same job but i
wouldn't be forced to be there i could
get to be there i could enjoy being
there and i could earn money but no
longer am i being used in order to
pay for a bunch of things that aren't
actually adding value to my life in the
first place did you enjoy this
stand-alone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free